Anything right now?
Just trying to reach you.
Always land on your feet, bro.
Your Jaime.
What the hell is that?
How did you get it to do that?
I think he likes me.
It’s on you're back!
Host Acquired
Okay.
It's going to be.
what is going on?
I think I caught a bus, and half
I can create
Oh, yeah.
Oh. It's like Batman stuff. Batman’s a fascist.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
DC just dropped a brand new blue Beetle
trailer with a whole bunch of Easter eggs.
Obviously, there's a lot of big questions
because of the big DC reboot.
James Gunn
rebooting everything into the DCU.
Blue Beetle is supposed
to be part of his new universe.
The way he explained it in his video,
couple of big name drops and jokes
about Batman too, like George Lopez,
his father calling Batman a fascist during
the SO will break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Just starting at the beginning of
the trailer footage Working way through.
Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs WTF moments.
So obviously the big thing is this.
Hi May. Reyez
is the third version of the Blue Beetle.
The original is Dan Garrett,
The second is Ted Court.
And then the third is Hymie Reyez.
It seems like they're changing
a couple things about his backstory.
Like in the comics, he's from El Paso,
Texas, which is where he finds the scarab.
They're changing how he finds the scarab
and changing a little bit
about how he interacts with the Ted Kord
character They explain in the DCU.
He lives in Palmyra City, which I think is
meant to be a sly wink at Ray Palmer.
I don't know if he's going to be
in this movie anywhere.
At the beginning of the trailer,
you just see his sister joking with him
about how he's just pretending
in not working like Earth to him.
You still doing your job?
We see Kord Industries as the main villain
of the movie is going to be Victoria
Kord, Ted Kord sister, who is a character
that they just canonized in the comics.
The whole idea is that
he's a love interest.
Who's going to be Jenny
during the movie steals
the scarab beetle from Cort Industries.
So the whole idea in the comics is quick
history.
On the actual blue
beetle scare of the Blue Beetle character
is that the original Blue
Beetle is Dan Garrett.
There's an Easter egg for him
in the trailer when he goes inside.
Ted Cordes
Layer Towards the end of the trailer
you see the classic blue beetle costume.
So you know, there was a Dan
Garrett and Ted Core did exist
because he finds all of his tech.
The Dan Garrett character
debuted in the Mystery Men comics
number one
during 1939, published by Fox Comics.
He was a police officer who drank
a special potion that gave him powers.
Initially, in the 1950s, Fox
Comics went out of business and sold
its characters and IP to Charlton Comics,
who retconned Blue Beetle's back story
and turned him into a professor,
introduced the Blue Beetle Scarab concept.
In the new version of his back story,
he found the scarab at an ancient
Egyptian archeology site.
The scare gave him powers,
but not quite on the level of Hymie.
Raya's in the 1960s.
They introduced the Ted Kord character
as Dan Garrett, student
who takes up the mantle of Blue Beetle
as Dan Garrett dies.
But he's unable to pass
the powers of the scarab on to him.
So Ted Kord uses his intellect
in all of his technology
to be a version of Blue Beetle,
which is where you get all the Easter eggs
towards the end of the trailer,
like the blue beetle ship,
his special lair.
It's kind of like a back door
Easter egg to Batman.
Like he was kind of a Batman version
of Blue Beetle, which is why
at the end of the trailer, George
Lopez playing Hi, May Ray is his father
makes the joke about Batman
like Batman is a fascist.
More recently, during the Infinite Crisis
storyline in the 2000s,
Ted Kord learns Maxwell
Lord is secretly trying to take control
of all metahumans on the planet
who then kills Ted Kord.
Later the high May Ray, his character,
found the scarab in an abandoned lot
in his hometown of El Paso in the comics.
But they're saying it's Palmyra City
during the movies.
It bonds with him,
giving him the true power of the scarab.
And he goes on to have adventures with
most of the teen titans Green lanterns.
He's a huge character
during the Young Justice series,
pricing him during episodes
and he crosses over
with the Justice League occasionally,
like they mentioned Batman
during the trailer,
But he mostly works with the younger
teams.
It's hard to say
what their plans are for him
in James Gunn's new rebooted DCU,
just because we haven't
even gotten most of his movies yet.
But the idea is that
these characters will all be connected.
They'll all cross over eventually.
The funny thing too, is that early on in
high May, Ray is his time as Blue Beetle.
The Peacemaker
character became a mentor to him,
so maybe they'll do a version of that
in the DCU because we know the Peacemaker
will continue in season two.
But during the trailer
you find that he gets a job at Kord
Industries and his love interest.
Jenny seems like she steals the scarab
from Victoria Court and gives it to him
Just trying to get it out of court.
Industries thinking that Victoria
is going to use it for something evil.
Guard this with your life gives it to him
in a big belly burger container.
So we're finally doing Big Belly Burger
inside the DCU.
I don't recall seeing Big Belly Burger
in any of the Zack Snyder DCU movies.
They use big Belly Burger
in a lot of the Arrowverse shows, though
I think they also use it
during the Smallville era in
there was a version of
Hi May Ray as Blue Beetle.
During Smallville era
there was even a full pilot that they did,
but they didn't pick it up to series.
So if you saw any of the Blue
Beetle footage from years and years ago,
that's what it was from.
Like they almost
made a Blue Beetle TV series,
but I don't think they had quite the money
they needed to do the special effects
for the suit at the time.
Now, the Jenny character
isn't someone from the comics,
so that might just be a moniker
that they're using
and she might be secretly
related to TED Court or Victoria Court
or something like that.
The scary bonds with him
like it does in the comics, and he starts
learning about the systems in the suit.
There is an air voice which is a
little bit different from the comics.
You don't usually hear an air voice like
an Iron Man type of voice inside the suit.
They probably added that
for the benefit of casual viewers
who just aren't used to the Blue Beetle
character in the comics,
and I love the special effects here,
they actually look pretty solid
in the way they portray his transformation
into Blue Beetle.
When it's assimilating with him,
they depict it as a very violent act
like it's taking over his body.
And that's very important
to the idea of what the scarab is,
what it does in the reach
when the voice says host acquired
and then takes him into the atmosphere.
Then later in the trailer,
you hear the Jenny character saying,
It's a world destroying weapon.
Sometimes it does what you want,
sometimes it doesn't.
That's meant to be a big twist
on the idea of what the rich do,
what their technology is, how it works,
how they take over other cultures.
So the whole idea is that the reach
is this ancient alien race with advanced
technology in the scarabs are meant
to be precursors to their invasion.
It's how they take over other cultures.
They'll send a scarab,
which they'll pretend
like it's going to help this new culture,
like it'll bond
with someone in this new culture,
this new planet.
Secretly, the rich will have command over
all the technology, so they'll turn that
host into their finger puppet
and use them to take over that culture.
The difference with the high
May Raya's character is that his scarab
was somehow broken a little bit
so that sometimes it won't listen to
what the reach tells it to do.
And sometimes it'll do whatever
Jaime Reyes wants it to do,
so that they're just teasing that idea.
When Jenny says Sometimes it does
what you want, sometimes it doesn't.
It'll wind up turning on him
and start hurting innocent people.
They kind of did this during Iron
Man two with roadies War machine armor.
Rhodey tries to use his armor for good,
but the systems take over
and start doing their own thing.
But here's the thing.
Susan Sarandon's Victoria Cord is meant
to be the main villain of this movie.
I think they'll only tease
the concept of the reach
at the end of this first movie, like,
Oh, there's an alien invasion
coming, by the way.
We should get ready for that.
And if the movie is successful enough,
then they'll do the reach in the sequel,
the way they depict his powers
in the trailer,
the powers of the suit
are pretty accurate.
That does pretty much
whatever he wants it to do forms
whatever he wants it to form.
Kind of like the way Green
Lantern rings work.
We do know that James Gunn is doing
a new Green Lantern series inside the DCU,
but it's going to be kind of like True
Detective
with the Green Lantern characters,
with Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart.
Maybe if things go well for Blue Beetle,
he'll have some minor crossover
with those Green Lantern characters.
If you're preparing for a space invasion,
the Green Lantern characters are the ones
that you would want to talk to.
It seems like the Jenny character
is the one
that leads them into Ted Court's
former lab.
This big array looks like it might have
something to do with the reach.
The other scarabs, like the whole idea
that there is invasion coming.
Maybe he'll get a vision of that
through the suit's systems.
Like, Oh, wait a minute,
what is it that I'm seeing?
This is a giant alien race
that's coming to kill us.
You hear Susan Sarandon's voice.
Is Victoria Cord saying the scarab
chose you, but it belongs to me?
That's right. Out of the comics.
You see her drones, her men
working for Cord Industries.
I think the whole idea is that during
the movie, Ted Court isn't around.
Something's happened to him.
He's disappeared.
Maybe they'll bring him back in some way.
But just like in the comics, when Jaime
Ray is first debuted, when he first became
Blue Beetle, Ted Kord wasn't around
to explain everything to him.
That didn't happen till later
during the new 52 reboot
and then eventually the DC Rebirth reboot.
Also, there was a couple of DC reboots.
They did bring the TED Court
character back and he started helping him.
Ray is giving him advice
and they both were there.
Versions of Blue Beetle,
you see them take off in TED Court's
classic Blue Beetle ship.
Like I said,
he has a lot of Iron Man style technology.
He uses his wealth, his intellect to make
tech to become a version of blue Beetle
because the scarab doesn't work for him.
Very animated, inspired action scene here
where the suit is telling him
he can create whatever he can imagine.
Whatever you can imagine,
I can create
a free.
Oh yeah.
Nice choice.
Then inside Ted Cord's lair,
we see a whole bunch of Easter eggs
in the background.
There's an Easter egg for Dan
Garrett's classic blue beetle suit.
Ted cords, classic blue beetle suit.
Then obviously, the joke from George
Lopez, his father talking about Batman.
Batman is a fascist.
Just because they're inside Ted
Gore is very Batman like lair,
like Ted Court the version of a bat cave.
I think part of the idea
is that going forward in the DCU
in the blue Beetle movies,
he'll just continue using Ted Cord's layer
until maybe Ted Kord shows up.
It depends on what they say happened
to him in the events of this movie,
the way James Gunn talked about it.
The movie itself
was relatively self-contained,
which is why
he was sort of allowing it into the DCU.
So I'm not expecting a ton of other
big crossover characters like Wonder
Woman isn't in this.
I don't think Batman is actually in this.
The funny thing is,
the movie is kind of like
a reverse version of the Bat Girl movie.
So if you remember famously,
Warner Brothers basically just
shelved the Batgirl movie and pretended
like they were never going to air.
Like no one will ever see this movie.
It had been intended on an HBO Max
exclusive, releasing
it wasn't going
to get a theatrical release.
They did the same thing
for the Blue Beetle movie,
like they were going to make it
just for HBO, Max.
But then when they were making it,
they decided that it looked so good.
Like it just felt like such a good movie.
The upgraded the budget
and turned it into a theatrical release.
So it kind of went the other direction.
That the Bat Girl movie went like,
No, no, no,
we need more people to see this movie.
So does sound like
it's going to be a pretty solid movie.
The trailer actually seemed pretty good.
If you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references
during the trailer footage
that it didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
We'll get more trailers with more of the
actual story in the next couple of months.
It's not coming out until August,
so it's going to be a little while.
The funny thing about this
is they actually featured Cort
Industries on Arrow, the Flash.
A bunch of the Arrowverse shows a bunch of
times in the Smallville universe.
They wanted to do him in the movies
for a long time.
It just taken this long
for special effects to catch up with it.
There's going to be a brand new Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse trailer tomorrow.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Of course I'll do videos for everything.
Everyone click here for that
brand new Marvel's
Secret Invasion
trailer video and click here
for my new Guardians of the Galaxy
three trailer, video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.